um let's bring in Ramy curri he's a
distinguished public policy fellow at
the American University of Beirut he
joins us from Boston um as Imran was
describing there Ramy we've seen this
huge increase in the scale and tempo of
Israeli raids across the West Bank since
the War Began what's your response to
the latest raid and and what they mean
on the ground
Ramy it's clear that the Israelis are
very very concerned that the uh
situation in Gaza is going to keep
spreading around the rest of Palestine
it's already had spread it's already
spread around the region you have
the theis in Yemen being active
militarily you have isbah and Lebanon
you have groups in Iraq and Syria uh and
they don't want the West Bank to erupt
in a big U um armed in Father there are
groups already working in in the several
of the towns and camps in the West Bank
these are small groups they usually
don't have more than 15 20 25 members
maybe um they're young people they're
not veteran Fighters usually and uh
these are spontaneous U military
resistance groups that have sprung up in
the last three or four years uh because
the Israelis have put in jail so many
hundreds of the previous generations of
leaders and and Military
activists um and and this Palestinian
Authority is not really doing anything
to protect the Palestinians so they feel
these young people have to take things
into their own hand okay and put up the
kind of resistance that's possible and
the Israelis want to stop this they
don't want it to grow yeah Ramy that's
an important point you make I mean
Israel says its intent uh in Gaza is to
destroy Hamas and and it's clear it
seems the objective of these raids
across the West Bank uh is about
eradicating those Palestinian armed
groups that in in the West Bank that
you've just mentioned as well as
Gaza well they they'd like to try to do
that but they I don't think you can
eradicate uh resistance by occupied
subjugated and humiliated and degraded
human beings who have suffered these
conditions for 50 60 years I don't think
you can just uh stop them from resisting
from fighting back somehow whether
peacefully or militarily so and and this
is really the story of human nature over
the Millennia which is degraded and
occupied people will resist whenever
they can they're they're being more
careful in the West Bank now because
they've seen how vicious Israel can be
they've seen their own leaders and their
own parents arrested or killed um over
the last 30 years and therefore they're
being more cautious about how they do
resistance they're not doing the kind of
resistance that Hamas is doing or hisbah
uh but they're just basically trying to
do a combination of small military acts
maybe set of improvised explosive device
set it up to blow up a passing Israeli
Jeep for instance a military Jeep or
maybe try to uh get a sniper to hit a
Israeli soldier and these are legitimate
Targets in international law that if
you're occupied you can and and also
it's the symbol symbolic action the
sense that gives the community a feeling
that somebody is trying to do something
to get us out of this terrible situation
we're in because the PNA the Palestine
National Authority is not doing it so
it's really a combination of these
things but these can grow very quickly
these groups uh because of the
frustration that exists due the
situation in Gaza um Ramy let's talk
about the occupied West Bank uh and rala
in particular um it's always been
slightly insulated hasn't it I mean it's
the seat of the Palestinian Authority
its economy has thrived ahead of Gaza
but given the sheer scale
of Israel's raids overnight has this do
you think burst that protective bubble
of the West
Bank this just Happ this is this has
happened before um it's not the first
time that this happens um they've been
and remember when ASAT was there they
surrounded him in the headquarters um so
this is designed to send a message to
the whole population um as well as
possibly to try to
arrest a couple of people who they may
have identified whether accurately or
not uh and to uh to arrest them but it's
really I think it's more preventive um
security work to try to send a message
to the rest of the population we're
going to do this every night now we've
done it every night for the last
whatever 40 nights and we we're going to
do it at a much bigger scale if anybody
tries to try to defy the Israeli uh
authorities that's my sense of what it's
probably
aiming to do the other thing it's trying
to do is the philosophy of Zionism in
the state of Israel is to get as many of
the Palestinians out of the land of
Palestine as possible because they want
a Jewish State that's what Zionism is
and netanyahu's government said it
clearly last year in their statement
that the only the Jewish people have
sovereignty and full rights in this land
from the Jordan River to the
Mediterranean which is Israel and the
occupied West Bank in East Jerusalem and
they've been using all kinds of tactics
to get people to leave to to make life
so difficult economically uh travel-wise
students who go to college have to pass
through five checkpoints and it takes
them four hours to get to their college
in the West Bank and four hours to get
home and if they give up they say this
is crazy I'll go so they're using all
these different tactics of which this is
the latest and most dramatic Ramy um
let's talk about some of the politics
briefly I mean what do these raids mean
for Palestinian president Mahmud Abbas
uh in rala I mean he remains deeply
unpopular to many Palestinians how much
political pressure does this put on his
leadership and also the Palestinian
Authority it should put a lot of
pressure on him but he seems to be
impervious to political pressure he he
seems to be like an automated figure who
just does his daily chores and goes to
the UN once a year year and makes a
speech I heard him last time he went he
was actually pretty unimpressive pretty
boring um he's too old to really do
anything serious uh he's politically
disconnected from the from the people um
well he's said almost nothing about Gaza
uh so he he's a man who is not really a
political actor anymore he's just a
symbolic figurehead and the Israelis
want that and the Palestinian Authority
that's what they want they want a
toothless actionless meaningless
Palestinian self-governing Authority
that can take out the garbage and fix
the electricity lines when there is
electricity um so that the Israelis can
go on with their settlement and annexing
land and uh and letting the settlers
free so he he's not really going to I
think react in any significant way other
than making a speech he might call a
meeting of the Central Committee of the
of the PLO which is really again a non
nonexisting body it's just on on paper
what what what has to happen is the
combination of re uh reconfiguring and
Rel legitimizing the whole PLO uh which
includes the Palestinian Authority but
the PLO that represents all Palestinians
and at the same time reestablishing the
links between Gaza and uh the West Bank
okay they've been separated for years so
these things are going to take time Ramy
just a final thought to you um and be
brief if you can what does all of this
mean uh in terms of the broader picture
as to what happens after the war I mean
there's this horrific conflict we're
seeing unfold on our screens in Gaza
these increased Israeli raids across the
West Bank Bank like we've seen tonight
and and as you point out the Israeli
Prime Minister dismissed any possibility
uh of a two-state solution what's all
this telling us then Ramy about how Gaza
How the West Bank will look after the
war there's no way to tell it really
depends on several things first of all
what happens when the fighting stops in
Gaza will the gazan people Palestinians
in Gaza be able to rebuild their society
will a a new governing mechanism come
into being that has credibility it can't
be defined by the US and Israel it has
to be defined by the Palestinians will
there be links with the West Bank and
East Jerusalem in many ways uh these
things are all question marks right now
there's no way we can answer these
questions what we do know is that the
Palestinians want National Unity they
want a PLO to be uh functional and
credible uh and they are perfectly
willing to negotiate a permanent peace
with Israel uh based on the Arab peace
plan that and we've already accepted
Israel's existence so we know those
things the question and Hamas is willing
to go along with coexisting with Israel
if all the Palestinians accept it uh and
if there's a good deal then the
Palestinians will accept it because you
know they don't want to just keep
fighting forever they want to live a
normal life and so do the Israelis the
Israelis must not be very happy
campers given the way what they've
suffered and what they're still
suffering and if they pull out a Gaza
Without Really achieving their goals
which is a possibility yeah okay Ramy
curri live for us there in Boston Ramy
as always thanks for your thoughts and
your
analysis you